for people to prosper peace and security
are essential today instability afflicts
the central african republic
dia congo mali sudan and somalia and
these conflicts impact on the rest of
africa and europe alike by fostering
terrorism piracy and drugs or arms
trafficking
the african union and regional
organizations are leading efforts to
restore peace with the backing of the
united nations and the eu
development support is also vital
from the african perspective we will
work tirelessly
to find solutions
to our problems but we may not have the
means
to implement and bring about those
solutions on our own
and hence we will then call upon
partners and the global community to
support our efforts
in times of crisis the goal is to
respond quickly when requested by its
partners the eu can provide humanitarian
aid to save lives and support refugees
at a political level under local
leadership the eu works with africans to
find home-grown solutions through
political dialogue and funding
but sometimes africa requests military
assistance in somalia africa is leading
the effort to combat militia forces like
al-shabab with its peacekeeping mission
amisom
europe plays a supporting role paying
amazon's operational costs and in
fighting piracy off the coast
eu soldiers are also teaching somali
officers to train their own troops and
rebuild the army part of europe's
comprehensive approach i want to
highlight the importance of inclusive
politics
rebuilding security establishing justice
institutions
these are fundamental building blocks
that will regain the trust of the people
and strengthen the social and economic
foundations of the country
european soldiers are also working at
the request of partners like ecowas in
mali to bolster the military which was
devastated by a series of coups and the
country's fight against terrorism
and in the central african republic with
its dire security political and
humanitarian problems the eu supports
the african-led peace mission and has
just endorsed a military operation to
secure parts of the capital
beyond that the eu and africa are
engaged in talks to stop the
proliferation of small arms
counterterrorism border security sexual
violence against women as well as
security sector reform in the great
lakes region